if you ever have to leave a man for your
job do it because you know what there
dozens of dicks but there's the that
career it's gonna take you [ __ ]
[Music]
hi I'm Ryan and I'm a video producer
dating dating is really hard I've done
apps I've done matchmakers and it just
doesn't work and I sometimes I'm like I
don't know what I'm doing wrong or
what's wrong with me but I've actually
never had a boyfriend I just have never
really found someone who I was into who
was into me feel like guys are really
bad at texting I however I'm an expert
bring on the Boies yes hi my name is
Elliot and I just finished grad school
hi I'm Dean I am an assistant to the
executive producer of carpool karaoke
hello my name is travail and I am a
performer it'll be interesting going in
not knowing what they look like and just
having their personality my dating
situation well I'm single AF dating even
like does it exist in 2019 in our
generation cruising is the new dating
I've done a lot of proving yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey everyone I'm third wheel describe
your perfect day and three emoji oh okay
Dean first off hot named his perfect day
is like hanging out with his dog which
aww I like puppies I'm glad he doesn't
have a cat he likes to run I'm not the
biggest fan of working out and then
movies Elliot says he likes to play
video games he likes to do what's honey
I don't know and then partying and then
travell with champagne bottle eggplant
and then the dancing girl so he likes to
drink have sex and then go dancing which
honestly not a bad day I mean growth
white diamonds we like eggplant which
celebrity do you secretly wish you could
be I would love to be Will Smith and
then also Beyonce oh wow Dean says
RuPaul
travell says ariana grande which I do
love so there's fun RuPaul's also great
I do drag so Dean is Dean is really
killing it right now send a pic of your
shoes oh okay
Dean's fashion sense is pretty dope Wow
he's got a great ankle I've never been
turned on by an ankle before but that
different are gay girl Elliot has a nice
fresh crisp pair of white Adidas always
classic love that oh my god can I've got
a picture of you that I don't have one
and then travails wearing converse in
comparison the other two just really
like really pop next question flannel or
silk sheets silk sheets girl flannel who
is she love silk sheets dry faster
drying faster like a washing machine not
drying faster friend said hope they
definitely need bodily fluids okay
Elliot says sheets don't matter only the
person next to me in that is truly truly
adorable yeah what's the biggest dating
deal-breaker for you none we can work it
out oh wow Elliot I mean so cheesy my
answers being late on the first date how
rude says travail that's
their team set drugs it's not a
deal-breaker but it's just interesting a
last one send a voice memo saying hi to
Ryan okay
Dean's message hi Ryan my name is Dean
hi Ryan
my name is Elliot I like how you have
two ends in your name it's very Elliot
said he likes the two ends in my name
hello Ryan this is my trade boy oh okay
this is hard I literally forgot this she
was right here recording this whole
thing and I thought I wasn't accountable
to my girlfriends just having a
conversation just now right and we're
all pockets of the same guy Dean really
had me in the beginning his emojis were
fun he also wanted to be RuPaul which I
love drag race he locked me in the hard
drive scenes because I like someone with
an open mind Elliot he's been really fun
to the thing I didn't necessarily like
was his first text his perfect date
involves video games it might be a
deal-breaker travels really funny with
his tray voice it was a good a good joke
made me laugh I have to make a decision
oh this is really hard I'm dead I'm
leaving I'm sleeping
oh wait is he gonna come out of this
door this is Dean oh wow
Oh Dean has such great style oh wow hi
what a cutie ahh
we can watch graduate that's fine
[Music]
welcome to round two and two to three
sentences share something that happened
recently that made you cry I thought
yesterday legitimately yes really so
there's that that was actually one of
the things that I was crying about this
week so obviously I can't use that well
you can that's something you can like
bond on you know I just spilled my guts
to him and he has a reply he has text me
back in the first two minutes
this is already not great oh no he said
my character was attacked and I was
framed as someone I'll never consider
myself to be we know then what happened
I'm not a big crier oh look at that the
fight big oh he said he's not a big
crier I like I'm a drag queen I'm a jack
win I wonder what it would be like to
date another drag queen it'll be great
because it'd be twice the wigs twice the
costume slice the shoes for more dollars
I love that play on words
Landon amor oh I love that we have
something in common that's really really
cool all right time is up Eliot you're
next go check your messages so now let's
talk to Elliot what's the hardest part
about being an adult the fact that I
never signed up for this hopefully he
finds the humor in that that's why
really been someone who can like laugh
about it figure out where to take my
career on what comes first I'm gonna say
I feel like career can be tough like
what if I'm a bomb-ass accountant I feel
like he knows who I am you think they
told him already I think so no they do
yeah they totally did they couldn't have
told him he is an accountant are you
kidding
there's no way something's fishy that's
crazy that's really crazy and if like
accounting is not necessarily something
you're super creative with so we'll be
doped and he has a cooking show oh my
god I love cooking I'm a producer in the
daytime and an amateur at sea ship owner
by nighttime I feel like that sex thing
Wow I'm very excited talking to Ellie oh
this is cute so he's not exactly well if
he doesn't see the possibility because
he can eat six thousand like a whole
bunch of stuff I'm not involved in this
conversation and you guys are having it
but yet I'm still here part
today I'm having a little FOMO oh no oh
no I'm sad that time is up and I don't
like it okay what am I thinking
um so many thoughts so many feelings I
feel like travel was a little bit slow
to respond and that is something that I
think would get annoying over time I
feel like our conversation was a little
scattered and all over the place but no
it was really cool I love that he was a
drag queen Elliott was really cool to
talk to I don't know how I knew he was
an accountant I was just joking and then
also when we were talking I found myself
rewriting texts I feel like that type of
excitement is something that you don't
get with everyone and there's something
that I don't get on dating apps oh my
god I'm nervous oh I don't know why I'm
nervous this wedding is getting serious
now Oh geesh let's get this over with
time to let somebody down oh you know
what it's okay I'm surprised I thought
he was gonna no I'm not surprised the
constraint I knew she was gonna steal my
wig anyways okay really
we're supposed to do our hair together
and our makeup that's how you felt it's
okay I'm so nervous
yeah I definitely did not expect that I
definitely thought that he was gonna
pick him oh nice to meet you Wow okay
when I was talking to you I feel like we
had the the most banter anyways I was
just I'm trying to be myself do you want
to go grab a drink I would love to yeah
yes let's go let's go right now
it's Friday I guess yeah right I don't
use a cool room thank
[Music]